hat der kreuzfahrtriese msc nicht dieses
und noch viel mehr in dieser sendung
viel spaß bei es geht um ihr geld ja
hallo und herzlich willkommen
schön dass sie dabei sind und wir
steigen gleich an mit einem wirklich
aktuellen thema und dazu ist uns auch
wieder unser rechtsanwalt zu gewaltig am
camp king r schaut uns aus gelsenkirchen
zu hallo herr champions alba berlin das
aufregerthema des tages wie ist das mit
innerdeutschen reisen ist also wirklich
sehr sehr verrückt man muss heutzutage
wirklich verordnung lesen um
herauszufinden ob ich von einem
bundesland ins andere bundesland reisen
kann zum beispiel eine sache schleswig
holstein sagt in berlin gibt es vier
bezirke die sind über die grenze das
heißt wenn ich aus diesen bezirken nach
schleswig-holstein er wieder zurück
reisen oder einreisen will dann muss ich
in quarantäne
das kann man sich ja gar nicht
vorstellen tatsächlich bei mir ist es so
ich wohne in kreuzberg kann meine eltern
die wohnen schleswig holstein zur zeit
nicht besuchen ist möglicherweise ein
einzelfall aber es könnte natürlich um
sich greifen am camp hits wie sehen sie
den fall dass wird absolut so weiter
passieren wir haben ja verschiedene
bereiche das in vechta dass es habe
beispielsweise das sind ja so bereich
oder teile eben von berlin die zum
risikogebiet sozusagen erklärt worden
sind und das ist genau das was im grunde
genommen die länder gefordert haben mehr
flexibilität auf länderebene und davon
wird jetzt ja auch gebrauch gemacht weil
es eben örtlich auch erforderlich ist
aber das führt eben wieder zu diesem
flickenteppich und das bedeutet nicht
dass ich die landes können sie nicht
überschreiten darf das bedeutet in
erster linie beherbergungs verbote das
heißt wenn ich irgendwo hinein werden
wenn ich in ein hotel will oder wenn ich
eine ferienwohnung gemietet habe und
dann das falsche kennzeichen habe dann
bekomme ich schwierigkeiten und es ist
wirklich auch ziemlich absurd wenn wir
zum beispiel mecklenburg vorpommern
nehmen die sie in berlin als gesamte
stadt das heißt dort sind halt noch
überhaupt keine grenzen erreicht und
schleswig holstein sieht halt einzelne
das hieße auch da drohen empfindliche
strafen also wenn ich zum beispiel jetzt
nach schleswig-holstein reisen werde da
erwischt bis zu 3000 euro bußgeld oder
wenn zum beispiel meine eltern mich
beherbergen würden würden noch bis zu
5000 euro dazu kommen das ist ja
wirklich wahnsinnig noch haben nicht
alle bundesländer solche verordnung
aktualisiert also es gibt zum beispiel
rheinland pfalz noch die haben etwas
ähnliches aber wie sollte ich jetzt als
ja meinetwegen auch urlaubsreisen da in
den herbstferien zum beispiel wie sollte
ich da jetzt vorgehen wo kann ich mich
informieren weil man muss tatsächlich
schon wirklich in das kleingedruckte
schauen also eine gute quelle ist immer
das robert koch institut
von dort aus gehen ja sozusagen die
impulse aus und da sollte man immer im
blick drauf haben für jeden auch
innerdeutsch und urlaub denn vor kurzem
haben wir noch gesagt bleibt in
deutschland macht dort urlaub aber
inzwischen sind auch in den deutschen
urlaubsgebieten quasi nicht alle
deutschen urlauber bekommen
aufgrund der örtlichen situation und das
macht die sache natürlich schwierig das
macht die situation über es auch
schwierig bei bereits gebuchten reisen
wenn man also beispielsweise eine
ferienwohnung gebucht hat und dann jetzt
aus berlin-neukölln kommt und irgendwo
nicht empfangen wird weil man eben sagte
airbus verbot dann wird von dort aus
eben storniert dann bekommt man sein
geld zurück wenn es aber andersrum ist
wenn die beherbergungs ort eben zur
verfügung steht man will aber nicht
dorthin kommt weil man beispielsweise
die wohnung in einem risikogebiet hat
dann sagt der gastwirt natürlich ihr
könnt ja kaum wenn ihr lust hat aber
dann muss man eben trotzdem bezahlen
oder über die stornierung bedingungen
eben gehen und dann muss man abschläge
hinnehmen
und noch weiteres detail ist wenn ich
als schleswig-holstein da vielleicht
gerade zurzeit in wenigen bin dann muss
ich auch bei der rückkehr in quarantäne
oder alternativ zwei corona tests machen
die dürfen aber nur fünf tage
auseinander sehen also es ist wirklich
sehr sehr nah und kempkes hat gesagt es
ist ein flickenteppich da wird
sicherlich noch mehr auf uns zukommen
reisen auch wirklich innerdeutsch wird
immer komplizierter und bevor sie
losfahren schauen sie erst mal ob sie
überhaupt tatsächlich in das gewünschte
bundesland einreisen dürfen
wir kommen zum nächsten aufreger thema
betriebsschließung versicherung haben so
gut wie alle gastronomen
abgeschlossen um natürlich zu verhindern
wenn wirklich der betrieb unterbrochen
ist sei es durch vielleicht durch ein
feuer oder vielleicht auch eben durch
eine durch eine pandemie in diesem fall
natürlich corona und jetzt stehen da
ganz viele auf einen schlag sagen wir
haben jetzt einfach total viele schulden
wir können unseren betrieb nicht richtig
aufmachen nur so ein bisschen das heißt
wir haben riesige einnahmeverluste und
tatsächlich diese versicherung die man
darf wirklich verteuert geld
abgeschlossen hat die zahlen einfach
nicht und wir sind verbunden mit marc
wilhelm er ist spezialisierter anwalt
für solche sache kommt aus düsseldorf
das ist doch wirklich wahnsinn da haben
wirklich gastronomen tatsächlich sehr
sehr viel geld und yang lange jahre
einbezahlt und am ende gibt's halt keine
kohle was sagen ihre mandanten
unsere mandanten sind enttäuscht also
das ist ja relativ ungewöhnliches
verhalten in der großen menge wie die
versicherer momentan gegen ihre
versicherungsnehmer vorgehen also sie
müssen sich auch vorstellen die haben
sich eine lösung ausgedacht warum sie
nicht zahlen müssen und oder nur ein
bruchteil eben 15 prozent und machen das
flächendeckend alle zusammen ist auf
wenige ausnahmen geht tatsächlich
reguliert und das hieße quasi verkennt
aus münchen da hat wirklich ein
gastronom tatsächlich auch wirklich
gewonnen und kriegt über eine million
ausbezahlt wir hatten ihn auch kurz in
dieser sendung muss ich denn jetzt am
ende klagen sie vertreten glaube ich
sehr viele gastronomen worum geht es da
genau also gegenseitig betreten wir
etwas 1000 betriebe die alle eine
antwort des versicherers bekommen haben
du kannst freiwillig von uns 15 prozent
haben oder eben nichts und entweder
nimmst du die 15 prozent oder bis dem
unzufriedenen wirst auf den klageweg
verwiesen
es wird keiner als individueller
versicherungsnehmer als individueller
schaden weil die sehen sondern es gibt
eine über den kranken schon eine lösung
mit der ansage der versicherer einen
versicherungsschutz bestünde nicht weil
sie an die pandemie ist aber genau dafür
ist ja die versicherung da also momentan
sieht so aus dass alle im grunde
genommen die wir hier vertreten klagen
werden sagen sie uns doch mal um wie
viel geld geht es denn da wir haben
jetzt gehört es ging hier
eine million das war der fall in münchen
wie viel geld würde denn bei einem
positiven urteil dann an ihre mandanten
fließen sagen sie mal wie es die spanne
da das ist ganz unterschiedlich also wir
vertreten die kleine bar an der ecke die
zwei monate zu machen musste die
hangenden ausfall vielleicht von 20.000
euro
wir vertreten genauso den ganz großen
hotelbetrieb die 567 millionen ausfall
haben über die entsprechende
schließungszeit also das ist wirklich
ganz gemischt wir haben uns da ganz
gezielt auch so positioniert dass wir
gesagt haben wenn dann helfen und wie
ist jetzt die lage wenn das geld jetzt
nicht kommt müssen da auch betriebe
schließen
wir sehen momentan sagen wir mal wenn
man es jetzt ganz groß ausdrückt geht
die strategie der versicherer im
gewissen rahmen auch dass einige
betriebe aufgeben und momentan würde ich
es auch so sehen dass das ganz
unterschiedlich hart getroffen ist also
die gastronomen die zunächst sehr hart
getroffen waren weil sie voll schließen
mussten können ja jetzt zumindest einen
einigermaßen sinnvollen betrieb wieder
tatsächlich machen aber wenn sie jetzt
die hotelbetreiber ots betrachten die
normalerweise business gäste h
entspricht also das klassische
stadthotel das davon lebt dass die messe
oder großveranstaltungen stattfinden
jetzt nicht mehr statt bin oder der
normale business reisende dort
unterkommen
die han richtigen zu kämpfen momentan
nämlich momentan reisen keine
geschäftsleute es gibt keine
großveranstaltung es gibt keine messen
wir sehen viele betriebe die sind immer
noch bei 20 prozent des
vorjahresumsatzes was natürlich ein
relevantes problem ist und gehen geht es
sehr schlecht und da fehlen momentan
unserer ansicht nach auch den
staatlichen
wir wollen noch mal ins detail gehen wir
haben jetzt zwei gastronomen getroffen
und sie erzählen sie ihre geschichte wir
haben einmal alexander hahn aus
frankfurt am main und er sagt uns dieses
hier sehr prekär zumal jetzt wir den
außenbereich so gut wie gar nicht mehr
nutzen können wir probieren jetzt
natürlich mit heizstrahler das ein
bisschen zu forcieren aber die leute
halt angst
rein zu gehen trotz abstand und was wir
alles einhalten corona mäßig
ich gucken wie sich das ganze noch
entwickelt ja ärgern tut mich natürlich
die derzeitige lage aber an der man
natürlich nicht viel drehen kann
von der politik wünschen würde ich mir
vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr
unterstützung oder dass nicht alles so
arg eng genommen wird gerade diese
abstandsregeln dass man das ein bisschen
verzerren könnte wir haben eine betriebs
ausfallversicherung die allerdings schon
reguliert hat bei mir sie haben mir ein
angebot gemacht was in dem ungefähr im
umfang entsprochen hat was mir eben nur
zugestanden hätte und da habe ich das
gleich zugesagt mit dem mit der
regulierung dann hätte ich gesagt ja
also herr hahn scheint einigermaßen
zufrieden sein
ankämpfen er hat er da möglicherweise
wirklich auch alles rausgeholt oder
werden noch mehr drin gewesen
also ich bin da etwas skeptisch denn das
sind ja in erster linie von denen wir
hören diese erst vergleiche geschlossen
wurden
das ist ein vorschlag sozusagen der aus
süddeutschland kam von dortigen
versicherung
die haben dann 15 prozent gezahlt haben
sich viele angeschlossen und dann wurden
solche vergleichs erklärungen
vorbereitet und da stand so sinn
ministerin
eigentlich müssen wir gar nicht bezahlen
wir zahlen aber so haben wir es gesehen
aus kulanz 15 prozent und dann musst du
auch den rest sozusagen sei es dass es
besteht oder nicht verzichten
und wenn man das dann unterschreibt er
ist natürlich sehr schwer nach zu fassen
denn man hat so ein bisschen den
eindruck dass ich jetzt die rechtslage
auch ein bisschen wandelt wir haben
dieses neue urteil aus münchen was eben
zu dem ergebnis kommt intransparenz und
das ist eine ganz wichtige keule im
versicherungsrecht und das ist ein ganz
wichtiger punkt auf dem man auch
weiterhin drängen kann also ich meine
dass man diese vergleiche wenn man sie
schließt wirklich ganz genau überlegen
sollte und nicht vorstellen
unterschreiben sollte daher will er wie
sehen sie das also einfach lieber 15
prozent haben oder jetzt einer
kostspieligen rechtsstreit initiieren
manche sagen da halte ich will keinen
ärger und bin froh wenn überhaupt geld
fließt gut man muss ja sehen dass die
gastronomen und hoteliers massiv unter
druck momentan sind das heißt für viele
ist das ein strohhalm an denen sie sich
klammern können
wir raten dringend davon ab die
vergleiche zu schließen
wir gehen davon aus dass in den meisten
fällen der anspruch auf die
versicherungsleistung im weit höheren
umfang gegeben ist und wie gesagt es
gibt ein paar versicherer die vernünftig
reguliert seien aber die große mehrheit
wir schätzen 95 prozent des marktes
bietet 15 prozent an
mit der ansage jetzt ist nicht
versichert und das halten wir jetzt
grundsätzlich für falsch also es ist
mindestens umstritten hier kommt zu
unserem nächsten gastronomen nicht
genügte den haben wir auch getroffen er
führt das parkhotel in plauen im
vogtland und ehrt uns das gesagt ich bin
nur flüchten
der besitzer vom parkhotel in glauben
ich habe eine
betriebsunterbrechungsversicherung bei
der mannheimer versicherung dort habe
ich wegen der korona erschließt zeiten
ab angefragt und über meinen
versicherungsmakler der hat das
weitergeleitet und als antwort habe ich
erhalten dass ich eine
betriebsunterbrechungsversicherung habe
die aber im falle von dieser situation
nicht greift das heißt über die
versicherung kann ich keine
entschädigung erwarten ich bleibe auf
meinen kosten sitzen die haben wird
dokumentiert aber da ist also nichts zu
erwarten
gegenwärtig habe ich einen ausfall von
circa 100.000 euro ja also wirklich sehr
sehr bitter an kempkens tatsächlich da
bleibt wohl wirklich nur der weg zu
klagen oder da scheint diesen fällen
wirklich so zu sein
und wir haben ja so verschiedenste
ansatzpunkte es gibt nämlich auch so
etwas wie beratungsfehler ja das heißt
wenn wir bei einem agenten
beispielsweise einen vertrag
abgeschlossen haben
dann wird dessen erklärungen wird direkt
auf dem versicherer zu gerechnet dass
denn sich auge und ohr rechtsprechung
und da wird sozusagen gesagt alles was
du dem agenten erklärt und der direkte
das ist im grunde genommen auch direkt
sache des versicherers das heißt wenn
der agent irgendwas versprochen hat da
kommt die versicherung da gar nicht so
leicht heraus
da haben wir noch den makler der makler
ist etwas anders rechtlich ein zu werten
also dessen erklärungen werden nicht
direkt dem versicherer zu gerechnet in
aller regel aber man hat möglicherweise
einen direkt
spruch aber beide makler und auch agent
müssen doch sachgerecht beraten
das heißt wenn ja wenn man hat ja schon
so im januar februar märz hat man doch
gemerkt dass da schon irgendwas passiert
und da hätte man vielleicht auch darüber
nachdenken müssen ob da etwas angepasst
werden muss um dieses risiko eben zu
versichern
und letztlich geht es ja um die frage
wer den alten verträgen ob das
mitversichert ist weil damals fehlte
noch die in bezugnahme zum
infektionsschutzgesetz in vielen
verträgen und das ist eben das was jetzt
das landgericht münchen aufgegriffen hat
also ich meine auch die chancen sind
ganz gut aber man muss in jedem
einzelfall genau hingucken er weder wenn
ich jetzt der besitzer der bar an der
ecke bin was muss ich denn da jetzt noch
einsetzen sondern rechts stand ist ja
nicht ganz billig lohnt sich das für
mich überhaupt einmal so wenn sie der
überzeugung sind und wir sind dass sie
hier chancen haben zu gewinnen müssen
sie natürlich ein gewisses risiko gehen
das heißt sie haben anwaltskosten diese
bezahlen müssen sie haben die
rechtskosten diese zahlen müssen aber
insbesondere im ballett ist unterliegen
wenn sie gewinnen dann bezahlt die ganze
sache die gegenseite als alternative
gibt es die möglichkeit so ein
prozessfinanzierer zu geben die aber
natürlich auch nicht alle fälle
finanzieren
aber hier sind wir frohen mutes dass wir
den meisten unserer kunden entsprechende
möglichkeiten bieten können so dass auch
risikofrei nebenkosten sinne geklagt
werden kann
ja also vielen dank herr wilhelm auch an
kempkens wünsche ich natürlich bei
anstehenden rechtsstreitigkeiten viel
erfolg und ich glaube das thema wird uns
auch noch weiter beschäftigen
vielen dank herr wilhelm gerne
willkommen zu unserem nächsten fall da
sind wir wieder beim hauptärgernis reise
ärger wir können jetzt im moment ja gar
nicht mehr verreisen wir uns vor
hingehört bei innerdeutsch geht es so
richtig und wir was sollen erst die
zuschauer sagen die jetzt noch altlasten
haben und da gibt es auch noch eine
ganze menge
wir haben hier das handy video von
rainer höhe bald aus gersthofen in
bayern
ich habe flugtickets nur flugticket ohne
hotel buchungen für flüge von münchen
nach fuerteventura
ich habe zufällig mein
den flugplan angeschaut und mir ist
dabei aufgefallen dass meine bestätigter
flug der 27 elfte gar nicht mehr
stattfindet sondern der flug auf
donnerstag den 26 10 11 verschoben
worden ist
auch crooner bedingt bin ich eigentlich
nicht bereit diese flüge anzutreten
frage soll ich abwarten oder soll ich
jetzt schon stornieren
meine frage ist auch noch mal kann ich
das kostenfrei tätigen
gleich mehrere komplexe berührt
tatsächlich einmal ein flug der
möglicherweise gar nicht stattfindet
aber noch gar nicht abgesagt ist
offiziell und tatsächlich auch ich
möchte eigentlich gar nicht fliegen
ankämpfen was sagen sie zu dem fall also
jetzt bitte nicht voreilig stornieren
denn wenn ich eine stornierung erklärung
abgebe setze ich ja ein rechts
mechanismus in gang und muss
möglicherweise einen teil der
stornierungskosten übernehmen
wenn aber fest steht der flug findet gar
nicht statt dann kann ich mich
eigentlich entspannt zurücklehnen denn
ich muss nicht akzeptieren dass der flug
einen tag vorher stattfindet wenn ich
jetzt für den 26 gebucht habe und dann
wird lange fliegen schon am 25
das muss der reisende nicht akzeptieren
das ist sozusagen ein neues angebot da
kann man sagen wir das akzeptiere ich
aber nicht dann kriegt man sein geld
zurück wenn man aber jetzt unsicher ist
was passiert dann sollte man jetzt die
fluggesellschaft genau damit auch
fordern dass man eben sagt aufgrund
meiner kenntnisse findet dieser flug gar
nicht statt
ich fordere sie auf mir zu erklären
findet dieser flug stadt ja oder nein
fristsetzung eine woche und wenn diese
frist abläuft dann kann man vom vertrag
zurücktreten weil das ja eine völlig
unhaltbare situation ist es ist für
einen reisenden unhaltbar dass er gar
nicht weiß ob der flug überhaupt
stattfindet vielleicht einen tag eher
stattfindet oder auch nicht und deswegen
kann man sozusagen die fluggesellschaft
durch solche aufforderungen in verzug
setzen ja wirklich ein sehr spannender
tipp tatsächlich merke ich dass auch
dass fluggesellschaften erst ganz kurz
vorher dann flüge storniert obwohl
eigentlich möglicherweise schon seit
monaten fest steht dass es den flug gar
nicht geben wird warum machen die das
wir machen das einfach weil sie
sozusagen in diesen fällen dann einfach
versuchen so die letzte frist
auszukosten denn wenn jetzt seitens der
reisen storniert wird dann sagen die
fluggesellschaften okay dann schau dir
doch dann kriegst du eben nur 20 30
prozent zurück ist natürlich besser als
wenn alles zurückgezahlt werden muss
wenn die fluggesellschaft stornierte im
grunde genommen ist es sozusagen für die
fluggesellschaft besser wenn die bis zum
letzten moment abwarten für den
reisenden ist das eigentlich auch besser
wenn der flug abgesagt wird denn wenn er
vorher aus eigenen stücken
beispielsweise weil er um verunsichert
ist weil er angst hat oder dergleichen
aus eigenen stücken viel vorher
dann ist das sozusagen eine erklärung
und dann bleibt er auf einem teil der
kosten sitzen das heißt für die
fluggesellschaften kann das sinnvoll
seien abzuwarten
ja das ist ja eigentlich schon vorsatz
oder naja das ist
ich würde schon glauben dass das noch
rechtlich noch so gerade zulässig ist
wenn man als fluggesellschaft
tatsächlich sagt wir wissen noch nicht
ob der flug vielleicht doch stattfinden
kann wenn man also noch die berechtigte
hoffnung hat dass der flug doch
stattfindet dann ist das in ordnung wenn
die fluggesellschaft allerdings heute
bereits weiß dass der flug in drei
wochen nicht stattfindet dann muss sie
darüber informieren das ist eine
vertragliche nebenpflicht ja wirklich
sehr spannend wir bleiben beim thema
reise ärger und wir sind jetzt verbunden
mit uwe beyer er ist rentner aus
riedheim und er hatte kreuzfahrt ärger
da ist weil wir mit seiner frau hallo
sie waren schon mal in der sendung und
sie haben das problem dass sie auf
kosten noch sitzen geblieben sind obwohl
die kreuzfahrt die liegt sowieso
irgendwie schief aber sie sind jetzt
zumindest wieder sicher zu hause aber
müssen trotzdem noch ja letztlich was
bezahlen oder zumindest kriegen sie ihre
auslagen nicht erstattet dabei erwiesen
moment der aktuelle stand worüber ärgern
sie sich also ich ärgere mich besonders
darüber dass man uns neues jahr halt
warten lassen und letztendlich die
ganzen ansprüche die wir gestellt haben
negiert hat es ginge nicht und man
könnte nicht und wir hätten keinen
anspruch
so kann es eigentlich in unserer
rechtsstaat nicht funktionieren dieser
rückflug gebucht wurden von der
kreuzfahrtgesellschaft über british
airways nach london
ja war schon entsprechend einer
pressemitteilung von british airways
gecancelt in das europäische ausland von
london aus das heißt man hat uns dort an
bord flüge gegeben und flugzeiten auf
die wir uns verlassen sollten wir wären
jämmerlich in london gestrandet und
hätten nicht mehr weitergekommen
außerdem kämen die sprache und kenntnis
da dazu und dann sind wir ich serbien
krebskrank und wir beide sind rentner
also ich weiß gar nicht wie das alles
gekommen wäre
hätten wir dorfen flughafen fußboden
schlafen zuhörer aus uns was wir werden
als london nicht mehr weggekommen so und
alles war vorher eigentlich mit der
deutschen reiseleiterin lisa fries die
auf dem schiff abgesprochen die uns noch
heilig versichert hat und sie die flüge
für sich selber wenn sie es können und
wenn sie es schaffen und sagen uns
bescheid was haben wir alles gemacht sie
hat bescheid gerücht beziehungsweise die
ganze rezeption und letztendlich noch
das jetzt total negiert wir haben die
sieben tagen nicht zurückerstattet
bekommen gar nicht und jetzt das auch
nicht also wir sitzen nach wie vor auf
der kompletten summe und worten ja wir
haben uns auch mit msc in verbindung
gesetzt die bleiben allerdings knallhart
die sagen wir haben dem paar einen flug
zur verfügung gestellt wurde das war
halt dann der flug wo man quasi in
london gestrandet ist und sie haben sich
dann selbst einen flug gebucht damit sie
halt auch nicht irgendwie am flughafen
übernachten können aber msi will das
geld einfach nicht zurückzahlen
an kempkens kennt den fall auch wie
sehen sie das
also punkt eins wenn so eine reise
abgesagt wird oder während der reise
abgebrochen wird dann bekommt man die
restlichen tage erstattet und der
veranstalter muss dafür sorgen dass man
auf dem gleichen weg wie man eigentlich
normalerweise zurück gereisten wäre mit
dem flugzeug beispielsweise dann auch
mit diesem flugzeug oder mit einem
anderen flugzeug natürlich aber mit dem
flugzeug wieder zurückgeführt wird
kosten übernimmt der veranstalter
wenn wir aber hier eine völlig
unbrauchbare möglichkeit angeboten
bekommen haben nämlich möglichkeit in
london zu stranden und das ist auch
sagen wir mal die ansage die der
reisende hat egal ob der flug dann
hinter tatsächlich stattfindet oder
nicht allein die angst dass man in
london strandet und sich dann irgendwie
dort um orientieren muss was ja vielen
gar nicht zumutbar ist und dem reisen
denn auch gar nicht zumutbar ist dann
kann man eine ersatz buchung vornehmen
und bekommt auch dieses geld erstattet
und dann noch ein dritter punkt der mir
total wichtig ist lisa dieser ist dieses
lisa argument der reisen das sagt ja
hier ich habe das vor ort vereinbart mit
der lisa aber da muss man das auch bitte
vorsichtshalber schriftlich machen sie
sofort bestätigen lassen oder
wenn das nicht funktioniert selber per
e-mail bestätigen das heißt man schreibt
der reisegesellschaft mit ihrer
mitarbeiterin lisa wenn man den
nachnamen nicht hat kann man sie auch
beim vorne an weiterhin und zwar die am
so viel und so und so viele nur an der
rezeption saß mit der ist das und das
vereinbart das bestätigt man selbst per
e mail
dem veranstalter denn dann hat man
hinterher auch so etwas wie ein
beweismittel
also ich bin wirklich fassungslos wie
msc wirklich einen namhaften
kreuzfahrtgesellschaft da wirklich mit
kunden umgeht herr beyer hat selbst
gesagt rentner dann kommen krankheiten
noch dazu und dann drohte das paar auch
noch in london zu stranden also liebe
msc manager haben sie da wirklich ein
einsehen die kreuzfahrt ist wirklich
schief gelaufen sie musste abgebrochen
werden wegen corona und jetzt muss herr
beyer auch noch oder sitzt auf 1400 euro
so teuer war nämlich dieser flug also
bitte erstatten sie herrn beier das geld
also und warum sind sie da so beinhart
also die wollen vielleicht auch gerne
noch mal wieder mit ihnen fahren
herr beyer wir drücken ihnen die daumen
ich kann ihren ärger ihren zorn absolut
verstehen wir bleiben auch dran
wie geht es ihnen heute ja ich habe nach
wie vor margendruck wenn ich daran denke
wie sich ein bisher hier verhält und die
deutsche rechtsprechung eigentlich sagen
sie haben das recht und sie bekommen los
hier bekommen gar nichts gar nichts und
da bin ich nach wie vor so sauer wie am
ersten tag
ich hatte eigentlich schon noch mehrere
kreuzfahrten zu machen aber ich sehe
mich ja jetzt gezwungen ich kann ja
nirgends zu was suchen beziehungsweise
in vorkasse gehen weil ich ja gar nicht
weiß ob ich irgendwann die reise durch
geführt bekomme beziehungsweise bei
stornierung das geld wieder zurück
kriegen
es ist da bin ich total von veranstalter
enttäuscht
das kann ich durchaus verstehen wir
bleiben dran aber diesem moment auch
sehr beinhart ob wieder was erreichen
können manchmal klappt halt auch nicht
immer aber ich verspreche ihnen herr
beyer
wir bleiben dran und komme auf diesem
fall auch noch mal wieder zurück vielen
dank wirklich ich wünsche ihnen alles
gute bleiben bleiben sie gesund und
vielleicht bis zum nächsten mal eine
kleine anmerkung
die stare dafür auch für den msc noch
nie die rede dass die rovers
zurückzahlen
als dann hätten die das schon mal und
wenn sie das in raten zurückzahlen
verhältnis schön auf unserem konto sein
müssen absolut da gebe ich ihnen absolut
recht und champions league dazu auch
herr beyer dann vielen dank dass sie in
dieser sendung waren und wir merken halt
das thema reise ist nach wie vor akut
werden sie da auch probleme haben wenn
ihnen auch noch jemand geld schuldet
dann schicken sie doch genauso wie auch
zuschauer in dieser sendung ein
handy-video an 01 71 9 59 22 11 oder sie
erreichen mich auch per e-mail ganz
klassisch ansparfonds bild.de und wir
würden gern natürlich in dieser sendung
auch über ihren fall berichten und
natürlich auch an kämpfte freut sich
ihnen dann auch helfen zu können
wir kommen zum nächsten thema das thema
sparen dem retten das an den leserpost
zuschriften da kommt ziemlich viel frust
rhein zum thema mobilfunk ärger jeder
hat da irgendeine geschichte zu erzählen
es geht halt um abzocke und es geht aber
auch um mangelnde netzqualität und
natürlich muss man sich da auch so ein
bisschen auskennt leider und deswegen
habe ich ihn mal zusammengestellt fünf
tipps für günstige mobilfunkverträge so
sparen sie bei mobilfunkverträgen bares
geld mein tipp 1 machen sie sich bewusst
brauchen sie wirklich eine flatrate in
alle netze oder reichen wirklich auch
100 minuten in alle netze
weil sie vielleicht noch einen normalen
telefonanschluss haben also ganz wichtig
checken sie brauchen sie wirklich eine
flatrate wenn sie am ende sagen ja gut
ich telefoniere so drei vier mal die
woche dann mit sicherheit nicht tipp 2
checken sie welcher anbieter hat an
ihrem wohnort das beste netz fragen sie
angehörige fragen sie freunde wenn die
halt sagen vodafone telekom oder die
funken hier gar nicht richtig dann würde
ich sagen hände weg tipp3 sind sie sich
da noch nicht ganz sicher wie viel sie
telefonieren oder ist das netz
ausreichend dann schließen sie erstmal
einen mobilfunkvertrag
mit monatlicher kündigungsfrist ab tipp
es ist immer günstiger einen neuen
vertrag abzuschließen stadt einen
bestehenden zu verlängern und sie können
einen kleinen trick anwenden das heißt
sie kündigen ihren 24 monatsvertrag
packen dann ihre nummer bei einem
prepaid anbieter und schließen dann von
dort aus wieder einen neuen vertrag ab
ist deutlich günstiger und vielleicht
gibt es ja auch noch ein attraktives
handy angebot tipp 5 handy ganz
wichtiges thema lassen sie sich nicht
durch ein euro smartphones in die irre
führen
am ende müssen sie es doch bezahlen und
es kann tatsächlich günstiger sein wenn
sie einen vertrag mit günstiger
grundgebühr nehmen und sich das handy
dazu separat kaufen
[Musik]
so das war es auch schon fast wieder an
kempkes mobilfunk ärger ist
wahrscheinlich auch ein dauerbrenner bei
ihnen oder ja das schon und darf ich
noch mal eins hinzufügen man sollte sich
unbedingt seine hülle kaufen ja ich
lasse sie nämlich immer runter fallen
dann brauchen unbedingt so eine schalen
hülle von hinten und von vorne auch noch
was aufgeklebt das was irgendwie dass
das hier dieses display wie schütze ich
hatte das eigentlich nie weil ich das
immer so schön fand wenn das so schmal
war das handy ich habe das immer
gelassen aber jedes mal habe ich das
handy geschrottet wenn ich aus dem auto
ausgestiegen bin da ist wenn das nämlich
aus der hose gerutscht aus der
hosentasche gerutscht und deswegen
seitdem ich deshalb habe ich zum
geburtstag geschenkt bekommen weil meine
tochter geht es wunderbar und ich
brauche gar kein neues handy das heißt
ich bleibe mal einen relativ alten ja
also es ist natürlich ein großzügiges
geschenk wir wissen an kempkens hatte
gerade geburtstag auch nochmal wir sagen
es gern noch mal noch einmal herzlichen
glückwunsch nachträglich wenn sie
jederzeit ihre erfreut sich nach wie vor
erfreut sich nach wie vor glücklich so
das war es auch schon wieder wir freuen
uns auf ihre fälle dann bei der nächsten
sendung schicken sie ordentlich ein
wir beraten sie wir schalten auch bild
kämpft ein unser versprechen wir sind
für sie da wenn es irgendwo hakt ich
freue mich schon auf die nächste sendung
schalten sie dann wieder ein klicken sie
wieder rein das war es für heute seine
chips sagt ihr und euer frank ochse
[Musik]